优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
字幕提供
所以比較趕一點
才剛吃完飯
好
有聲音加個1
有聽到聲音喔
好
那我們今天要講這個
揭秘神秘的分點
大禁場的口袋名單
那這些
大禁場的
其實神秘分點它有分成
全證跟
跟獻股
全證跟獻股
那這個常常做的交易裡面呢
都會
都會看一下這些神秘噴點最近在買什麼
在買什麼
因為這個神秘噴點買了之後
最近有的都很噴啊
很噴
好
來來來
我們來看一下這個這兩天最噴的一檔股票
這兩天最噴的一檔股票也蠻猛的
蠻猛的
各位來看一下
這個一下子拉了三根漲停
拉了三根漲停
然後呢這個
呃 各位來看一下他分點喔
分點蠻厲害的
就是鎖漲停 很厲害
來 2337
這是
這三天來最強的股票
最強的股票
又大型又強
今天居然觸發了
有觸發第一款 第二款 觸發一堆
好啦 那旺宏呢
各位看一下喔 旺宏呢他在這一天那他在那一天這天拉了漲停了那就有人問說那松山哥是誰那松山哥呢他是一個所漲停的一個所漲停因為你穿他的股價就知道了所漲停
蠻猛的他不只會所漲停他有時候會以為敲跌停
我在市場上算是一個厲害傳奇的一個分點啦
松山哥
然後呢他去敲了這一檔之後呢連續兩個這個漲停都沒出
他没出
那他买完之后呢
变成是跟谁买
跟国泰断跟散户买
所以这行股票是
散户的
股票流到了主力身上
那这三天的主力呢
我不确定冲山哥会不会做短线
不确定
平常做短线啊
但是这个旺宏的新闻实在太惊人了
旺宏新闻说什么目标价300嘛
这个新闻写的
外资订300嘛
我不晓得会不会300
我不知道啦 这个没有任何背书
哦 好不好
这里啊
法人高喊这场记忆体股今天价
各位看一下 很恐怖啊
这个这个股价
哎
有没有目标价
对啊 有啊 高喊300元今天价
有没有
高喊300元今天价
潜在上涨空间打2倍
所以呢 这个
就被索馬了
那這兩天就非常強
這兩天很強哦
那因為很強也觸發了一些注意
所以沒有意外的話應該是
後天是有機會關的
因為他現在已經觸發了這個
出發了好像九天有五天了
所以他已經停牌了
那今天呢他盤中其實
你可以看得到盤中
他已經有出量了有沒有
這裡盤中有出量
所以呢
呃因为盘中有出量啊所以
最高的风险呢
就会增加
假如盘中没有出量那当然最高风险比较小啦
那盘中这边有出量
那这量谁卖的呢
各位来看一下我们可以从车中这边看
这量呢是元大卖的
所以今天呢是元大去锁
不是元大有去锁一些
但是他们卖更多
因为他们去锁是这样子啊
锁呢
锁的过程中呢他也会去领号码牌
各位看一下这里
他们锁完之后都会去做一件事情啊
都会去看那个list 就是看一下说
自己是排到排到哪里啊 例如说买完之后那后面他就可以来看他的成交有没有排到因为各位你看一下今天是跳功一字线锁死吗
所以呢第一笔单出来之后
假如大户丢很多单他就可以知道说
呃今天中的概率有多少
然后呢盘中呢他假如又吃到的话他大概就可以知道说自己是拿了几号的号码牌
例如说你吃到这张你就知道说你是拿了14583号号码牌
那你假如吃到
假设
假设你吃到了这个你就知道说我原来拿到25000号号码牌
然后呢他们会在跟盘中的这个买盘呢来做个
那个研究了因为他研究一下
这买盘到底是是真是假
所以他们在里面也会怎么样
也会偷偷的换位置啊换位置就说他敢把单子删掉然后又跑到后面去
然后呢他就可以知道说他自己到底是排几号
所以呢这中间呢他有的会偷换位置
反正这一切的一切呢就是要确保说自己
万一在涨停被敲开的时候自己要赶快敲开了好
那可能
元大呢他有吃到自己的单人也知道自己的单子排的号码牌
吃到代表说他今天
賣出的
那個
賣的話可能會比較安全一點
所以他賣了
他選擇賣掉
圖神永林也是有去鎖
但他也選擇賣掉
凱基有去鎖
那賣掉賣不完
富邦也有鎖
他也選擇賣掉
凱基設政也有鎖
他可能覺得明天不會開高了
所以呢這邊呢
有一大堆
可能覺得今天可能會開
選擇先賣掉一些
所以這邊呢你可以看到有買有賣
有賣有賣
你不要覺得說幹嘛這沒事有買有賣的
他不是沒事
他是號碼牌的關係
好不好
號碼牌的關係
好這跟各位講他是一個號碼牌的關係
所以呢這個因為號碼牌的關係
我的萬華配早就出場了好不好早出場了
因為號碼牌的關係啊所以呢
这个呃你就不知道说
呃那我们可以很肯定很肯定的
这些一定都是短线
这边很多个短线了那国票台中间嗯肯定是噎的有点用力那國標台中是不是短線呢不知道通常買漲停滿多短線啦
各位這個要買漲停也不是那麼好買的
要去排隊
要有錢
好不好
所以呢
這些人搞不好明天也有想
也可能想出來
反正就這樣子
我現在目前是
呃
大家都這個有可能
有可能最終
後面的那個股價會很高
但是他有可能是震盪在往上
他沒有不一定會一下子就往上走
喔好不好
也不見得一下子就供到300塊
不會啦 因為畢竟他的股本很大
那有可能 明天
明天有可能 因為他已經已經聽牌了
好 聽牌了
所以呢 我們來看一下
來 他聽牌了齁
聽牌了我的處置神器
我看一下 我看一下能不能看
我看一下 我連一下我的設備
我連一下 因為他聽牌了啦
那我們今天
呃 聽牌了我們就
你假如有研究處置的話
你就會知道說
他今天聽牌之後
他
他的
這個
明天聽牌的條件
那我們今天剛好有
剛好有研究他明天聽牌的條件了
等一下
所以呢
我來看一下
喂知曉
我們現在呢有設計一個
App啊
這App還沒有還沒有
還沒
還沒開賣
好不好
沒有開賣
所以我最近都一直在 test 這個 app
那這個 app 呢就可以告訴我們怎麼樣
各位看一下
喔有沒有
這影片就可以告訴我們說明天萬宏聽的條件
好啦他有一個條件嘛就是價格123
然後量是9萬3
這是明天的一個條件
你就以上僅空參考
這個不代表一定正確
好不好
因為這個預測嘛
這是預測而已好不好
預測而已
他並沒有預估好不好
他只是預估而已
那這裡呢
會有那個實際的量跟盤中的一步量
這盤中會跳
那我現在盤中我都會打開來看
打開來看
因為他假如有符合他就會亮燈
所以很簡單
有符合就亮燈
所以我就知道說
他有沒有可能明天被關
那被關也不代表一定跌啦
再跟各位講
被關不一定跌
但是呢
我們有做統計啦
給各位看個統計
這邊
統計給各位看
所以儲置呢有個統計蠻好玩的在這邊啦
儲置其實中後段之後是蠻容易漲的
好不好
中後段之後是蠻容易漲的
那在這裡面還有一些
蠻
蠻寶貴的東西
那這麼寶貴的東西
還有一些
我是覺得
寫的蠻
蠻重要的東西啊
那這重要東西我們在公開平台就不要講太多
例如說我們有那個什麼雙刀戰法
雙刀戰法
雙刀戰法 徐賴說
前幾天呢 我有跟各位講一檔股票
不曉得各位有沒有印象
這一檔
我有說啦 我有說這個 我有空聯亞
我有空聯亞 因為他符合處置
處置前面他的
他的那個總是比較弱
他的走勢比較弱
他最近他處置之後 他就是走勢比較弱
雙刀戰法裡面呢 有一個很值得一配的
我們這一配的叫做
欸
叫做
光聖
那時候是那時候是50幾趴
喔
那時候是50幾趴
這裡
而且已經來到39趴
所以我的我的
連光配是
大獲全勝嘛對不對
連光配我是做多光聖那算光聖有跌啦
但是聯亞跌更多嘛
聯亞跌更多所以我整體的組合是
是賺的
從56%到39%
反正這個是比較進階的啦
比較進階的他就要去看一些
美感啦
美感我們就不要講太多了
那這些東西呢
我們
比較基本的一些東西
我們會有一堂課
這堂課呢會跟各位分享
等等等等
來來來
這堂課
高勝率處置策略線上體驗課
歡迎各位報一下他是不用錢的這是理財老辦的一個直播 不用錢全套軟體有要包含這個軟體嗎目前的全套沒有這一套
因為它也沒上市
那以後的全套會有這一套
但是它的價錢不會跟之前一樣
不會跟之前一樣
就這樣子
所以那個目前的狀況是這樣
免費但是限額
他会教各位
其实我那个双刀
我就常常用这个
因为它就是符合我想要的
它是符合我想要的模式设计出来的嘛
所以呢我就会在里面呢
做一些双刀
这种双刀
也不是一定赚钱啦
跟哥们讲他没有一定赚钱这种事情
做任何交易都会有风险
只是在做双刀的时候
其实你的胜率会比较高
你也比较安心一点
比較安心 因為你是兩個部位
因為你只要只有一個部位 你很擔心啊
因為最近那個美伊戰爭嘛 對不對
只有單純做多你也怕
好不好 純做多你也怕 純做空你也怕
現在盤中的波動這麼大 對不對
盤這個 不要說盤中了 盤頭的波動
常常台子旗漲跌千點
漲跌千點 寧願是真的 寧願是真的啦
寧願是真的 它只是一個限量
限量的體驗
欸 各位搞不好 因為那個有限量
那他只是 欸 這就是直播啦 我就直播
然後再給各位講說 欸 最近雙刀 我們
我們因為這個軟體 我們有做
做哪些的這個交易
啊這些交易呢 要怎麼看
這雙刀裡面會講
就講 就這樣子啦
這個是利用
利用處置策略
處置策略不是叫人做空 沒有沒有沒有
他有大部分是做多的
好不好 他有大部分是做多的
然後他有很多 多空可以做
其實 在我們的試技課裡面
試技課裡面 其實
試技課裡面呢 都有那個
欸 全套送一個月
有沒有包含 欸
你要問小秘書
哈哈 小秘書
然後在全套一個月有沒有包含
這問小秘書 因為那個 那是他
好 用家裡植
呃
不是自學網啦 不是自學網
現在這個是理財寶場是不是
啊 理財寶場
那這個
這軟體叫處置神器處置神器那它會它會研究一些數據啦研究說他的量價門檻那他背後有一些比較深的東西
這個我們
我們上課再來講
上課再來講
反正這個
各位你可以
體驗看看吧
體驗看看
那這個
處置
處置我是覺得蠻有趣的
沒有意思的
好 那處置神器呢 可以幫助你 怎麼樣
提前掌握處置門檻 讓你找到交易機會啦
因為他有 他有統計嘛
所以這邊有 處置日報
處置日報 明日預測準確入高達99%
1%是規則上限 不是我們的極限
因為他有些
有些規則
你沒辦法預測得到
我舉牌說啦
舉牌說 他有些規則是
買超第一名的分點佔幾%
你怎麼預測到啊
你哪預測到買超第一名佔幾%
我哪知道買超第一名要佔幾%
你懂嗎
他買超第一名佔幾% 他就被關了
所以有時候會有一個這個門檻
這個門檻你根本預測不到
我哪知道今天誰買啊
對不對 趕快那個人跑去看球了
他又不買 對不對
所以那個沒有辦法
所以有時候
大部分都猜得到
有些猜不到
啊 拍得到呢 就趨吉畢胸 好不好
趨吉畢胸
那有些主力呢 他也會趨吉畢胸
那趨吉畢胸 舉例來說啦 舉例來說
有一張股票叫做波羅威
波羅威
波羅威這張股票呢 他要被關了
他要被關了
這被關了
要被關
喔 要被關呢
呃 這個 波羅威要被關
所以呢
這個阻力齁
你想想想我是阻力的話 我可能今天我都想跑
所以今天波羅威的阻力呢 就趁今天跑
因為他也是要被關嘛
趁他趁今天跑 所以今天波羅威就特別弱
我就這樣子 齁 就這樣子
欸 林圓是真的嗎 當然是真的啦
希望你有承載上線啊
到了會自己關閉
對 他沒辦法一次太多人看
所以可以報名就報啊
反正這個我們是
報名 然後再來後面會來講解好啦所以處置是這樣子齁那他他有很多東西
我來看一下
這邊有很多東西啦
他有他的
處置的統計
來
再給各位看一下
他有處置的統計啦
有一些股票处置的第一天是怎么样
这边有统计
来来 这边有统计
统计内容给各位看啊
这股票呢处置前一天
像波卫就是处置前一天大跌
那有处置前一天他就涨停牌开出
那这个我们会跟各位讲
他其实是有个眉角在里面
就是 例如说像晴云
清雲就跟妖股一樣
清雲的老闆應該是開始賣的啦
各位看一下 清雲老闆在賣股票了
這裡
這雙手應該是他啦
我猜啦 我猜啦 我強力懷疑
我強力懷疑是他
因為清雲他的
老闆身貿轉讓嘛
啊賣那麼多張的
可能是啊 我不確定 不確定
賣一千張 有沒有
再賣一千張 那可能他就分批賣
分批賣
所以你看可以賣66張66張的應該是
應該是那個
應該是大股東啦
我可以賣那麼多張
感覺起來有在賣
因為一般交易
一般交易
所以輕語呢是有在賣
那這些統計呢
呃
反正這裡會有一些統計
有些統計
所以呢你可以看得出來說
處置錢的狀況
這邊都有
都有啦
啊這到底這怎麼看呢
我們以後呢再跟各位講
這個我們上課再來講啦
那這邊有很多什麼
紅黑的機率啊開售的沙卜這邊很多
然後
我覺得重點是他可以
他可以做雙刀我覺得蠻厲害的
做雙刀這真的很厲害
雙刀
就來說威剛好了威剛
威剛就很強嘛對不對
那明天有可能被關
你看這邊就寫得很清楚
明天有可能被關
那我们就会有双刀 双刀怎么做 处置统计怎么做
好 这个是微钢的状况
微钢之前的处置的统计的状况怎么样
所以这个软件
算是 我是覺得做得蠻細的啦
做得蠻細的
所以裡面有很多東西
我們禮拜四再來講啦
禮拜四再把整個儲制的概念呢
再講一遍 因為有的
有人現在跟他講 他也不知道什麼叫儲制
你儲制什麼都不知道
所以禮拜四呢 我們就
從儲制的概念開始講
先講一個
那個初階班
初階班
然後
威剛變威爾剛
這個我們以前就跟各位講了
這個
這個影片是我在
之前拍的啦
這邊有一個影片啊
是我之前拍的
威剛變威剛這裡
這裡
這影片我之前拍的
那時候
3個多塊
對啊
其實我那時候是在那時候講的
所以那時候籌版其實很漂亮
籌碼而美 位階最低
對不對
所以其實你可以從
那個創造裡面你可以找到一些位置低的股票
然後來做配對
來做配對啦
所以就這樣
所以那個整個過程是這樣
整個過程是這樣
好 各位有興趣
來 歡迎報名這個免費的體驗課程啦
免費課
我就先把那個處置的概念先講一遍
跟你講一遍
好
你廢課就這樣子了
但是
這個
這課第一個他
這個課你外面買不到啦
因為也沒在賣
那第二是
也沒有回放
這課沒有回放
沒有回放
就是沒有說那個錄完
然後放在YouTube給大家看
沒有好不好
所以直播就直播
沒看到就沒了
這課是這樣子的
好 所以各位有興趣的話可以報名一下
因為最近的那個
儲置的股票非常多
這很多
這裡有一堆儲置的股票
儲置的股票
那我們這邊呢還有一些
哇這儲置股票其實蠻好玩的
儲置的股票蠻好玩的
就是你可以看到
这些储置的股票
然后呢最近呢他的跌幅有多少喔 文真有喔 來 給各位看 這裡喔
哇 儲置股票剩幾天 喔 這個是已經坐牢的
三龍跌了30%啊 喔 恐怖啊
印廣跌了18% 歡迎跌了13%
喔 這裡連亞跌了13% 從儲置以來跌了幾%
這邊呢 會有一些數字 給各位看
可是這裡面的內容我覺得很多啦 很豐富
歡迎各位 歡迎各位看 好
好啦 那以上呢 是這個
呃 處置的這個課程
有興趣的可以加
一開始請會加這幾個QR Code啦
Tayvour粉絲團
Light 光順人 YouTube 跟IG
那我們PP有訂閱喔
PP會每天會研究關鍵分點的籌碼
每天有研究關鍵分點的籌碼
來給各位看一下昨天的關鍵分點
昨天的關鍵分點
我們就有看到昨天的分點買賣的狀況
這PP寫這PP的內容
關鍵分點買賣狀況
關鍵買的有哪些
關鍵賣的有哪些
這裡都有寫出來
都寫出來
這個是PP的狀況
關鍵買賣超
關鍵買賣鈔
這裡有
所以你要知道關鍵分點買賣什麼的
可以從這邊看
那PPE有一些那個
這個
全正大陸分點
這邊有啊 全正大陸分點
像我們最近追蹤的一檔
我覺得還不錯啦
應該後面還是有大有可為的
像這個華泰
我在理財答案就有講啦
華泰 漸漸他的月線怎麼要
感覺要翻養了 感覺啦
那華泰有華泳上台中
除了華泳上台中以外還有元大藍屯
然後事實上有兩個大分點呢
都繼續買
而且還有富翰公益
這台中分點啦
這邊很多台中分點
然後台中分點 好
而儲置大碟出關是不是有機會
沒錯沒錯
這是一個
這是一個那個
這是儲置大碟出關有機會
沒有錯
欸隨速有認真買
欸來看一下
呃
來
水數最近實施庫長股啊
越實施股本越來越低啊
啊
股本越來越低呦呦哇塞好認真喔唉呦這麼認真喔喔 會不會太認真連買4天了呢
喔 連買4天了
等一下看一下
連買4天股票
連打
欸
對啊
4000多張
對
連買4天4000多張 被大魔盜貨
這個最近有認真買
家機為何又被20分鐘
為何又被20分鐘啊
啊你上完處置客你就知道了
處置客呢有他的那個
knowhow嘛先把knowhow告訴你
你先知道處置客的knowhow
然後你再看一下處置客的
那個後面的內容
那我們以後呢再來檢討一下
我們不是要預測啊我們是要檢討
其實儲置我是覺得檢討很重要
檢討很重要
這個我們儲置股
儲置股
那這邊儲置股有他的資訊
那我們這邊是課堂案例
唉呦你看這麼多
唉呦會不會太多啊
課堂案例
這個是儲置股後面的走勢
他的注意啊儲置啊後面走勢
然後呢你多看幾次
你多看幾次呢你就知道說
欸哪個點呢
你是該做多的
哪個點該做多的
反正這個處置課程這裡面都會有
好
課程的全套三折裡面包完這軟體沒有
沒有這個以後
以後才會有
因為這是他們新做的
所以他們都沒有含在
舊的全套裡面
反正行銷的東西喔
各位你可以問一下小秘書
我只帶一知道這樣子
現在版本沒有包含
那未來會包含的
但是未來價格
好
那歡迎各位加這社群
那社群呢是密碼4個8
密碼4個8
歡迎加個社群
歡迎加進來
要討論什麼都可以在裡面討論
裡面的人蠻多的
蠻多的齁
這個
呵呵
盤中都會有一些討論的
他們都在討論的盤中比較少在裡面聊天盤中比較少在裡面聊天喔盤中比較少在裡面聊天然後
所以各位 歡迎架一下
裡面討論的蠻
蠻不錯的喔
然後
欸
各位記得報名啊
0元夠
0元夠啦
喔 至少
上完課後你會教你一些處置的概念
按照概念就好
照概念呢你就照說
趨吉必凶啦
就這樣子
好啊 趨吉必凶
評估加上加差
他以後會評估啦
以後評估
好啦
反正你先報名就知道啦
好
接下來是那個
世紀投資法最近那個時速開
支島開的
支島開的課程
世紀投資法
世紀投資法呢我們來看一下
最近有些股票
我們可以直接來看
他的
他的狀況
喔
世紀投資法
我們可以直接給各位看一下
喔
這個最近那個他的
股票狀況
好我們來看一下
韜鴻金的籌碼一下
夏天
那夏天的股票呢
哇最近望紅夏天嘛
哇夏天
純純夏天
對不對
星星夏天嘛
对
那今天遇到了那个
巴小姐的
狙几
巴小姐直接买星星
一买变黑黑
蛮厉害的
尹薇夏天
雍智夏天
这还是夏天哦
佳基夏天
瑞森夏天
这还是夏天
元金夏天
但我覺得元金比較碰
元金比較碰
不要碰 這邊有雨沾
夏天
哇 雨沾今天多狠啊
拉到快漲底 然後翻黑啊
有夠狠 你知道
超狠
這裡啊
可巧 夏天
這邊有很多夏天股票
那秋天股票呢 有很多
我給各位來看一下
最近有一些秋天股票
南亞克秋天
那哥算長這樣喔 但他定義上
目前的型態看起來還是糗點
喔 目前型態看起來還是糗點
妹妹說沒看到我是睡不著
好很好
群年也是啊
群年定義上還是秋天
所以今天我有空那個藍牙哥跟群年
其實其實我蠻喜歡
這個短空的話喜歡找秋天空
短空找秋天的空都還不錯啦
都還不錯
短空的各位你可以考慮找秋天的空
你看這裡這是秋天啊
秋天就是月線有點走平的
然後籌碼其實沒有很好
喔 各位有沒有看到 它籌碼沒有很漂亮
喔 籌碼沒有很漂亮 秋天的股票
喔 然後它有的是漲多的
納克群聯是漲多
那他們有沒有機會再創高呢
喔 有沒有機會再創高
這個沒辦法跟你肯定
沒有 它現在只是
形態秋天 籌碼秋天
我們這個還有那個籌碼的過濾
籌碼的過濾
形態秋天籌碼秋天
就這樣
好看春天了 春天一堆啊
春天有很多
這邊有很多殖利率不錯的春天
但是營建股你就可能不要了
不要營建股比較安全啦
營建股的殖利率我是不大敢要
這邊很多
春天的股票
哦好所以這個春夏秋冬
都有好不好春夏秋冬都有
各位可以
好的研究
好那這個怎麼做
怎麼做呢這邊市議投資團有明確的介紹
哦那夠客會想每月更新時代影片一支
哦那
升級價值方案這邊限定
那今天有直播限定快展折扣券
是只有今天可以使用
670人折600
好 就這樣
各位有興趣的可以看
好 那我們來看一下今天的主題
先來看一下學員的回答
上圍這樣子
哇
感謝小哥每天批評更新讓我學到非常多關於
其他4D課程
我希望賺到學員多拉A夢
月小也好 我再找一個小的送給你
找一個小的送給你
Polimor
然後呢 四季規律很有啟發
讓人期待在這方面這套方法可以知道股票季節變化掌握到換季時機好那我們來看一下這1、2月份的損益
1、2月份做得還不錯
還不錯齁
1、2月份那個
這個期貨做不錯
3月份的期貨也做還不錯
什麼時候全課程
可能要下半年了
沒那麼快
好 然後
今天的主題齁
今天的主題
喔 我們先講一下
那個可轉載的入門班
喔 目前
那個台中高雄場都完了
都已經上完了
兩個都滿場了
台中高雄超多人
台中滿場 高雄 哇 滿滿人
滿滿人
那台北場
欸 台北場剩幾個位置啊
台北場應該也剩不多啊
那個可轉載客
可轉載客 我們會
可以好好地解釋什麼叫可轉載
喔
台北場剩32
欸沒沒沒
欸不是沒
我說錯了
唉唷
處置策略剩34個
喔 要報告一報
台北場剩10個啦
剩10個
剩10個名額
好 可轉載最後一場
這入門基礎班
喔 那我們之後有進階班
我們會教動態避險
動態避險我覺得很好
喔 就是動態避險
很多時候你還怕買可轉載他倒
你做的動態 那個
他倒
他倒就連續跌停嘛 所以你的動態呢 還可以再賺另外一筆
有機會加入小哥團隊 什麼團隊 出國團隊嗎
出國團隊有機會啊
就是熟了之後 有機會啊 他們現在
那個
我們高雄廠
有很多學員都是
每次會跟我一起出國的
啊他們還是還是繼續報名高雄廠
每個禮拜都都會去
每個月不是每個禮拜
每個月他們還是會去高雄廠看我
啊看我這個啊之後我們就一兩個月會出國一次啊
下一次還沒
還沒缺鳥時間
理財寶的可轉代課跟星系哦
當然報最新的啦
你假如還沒報你就報最新的
反正各位記得什麼課你就報最新的
因為最新的最新的東西啊
像我們這堂課我們就有講一些那個
因為最近可轉載喔
最近可轉載已經變成一個
人氣我取的狀況最近可轉載他是一個眾人恐懼我貪婪喔 可轉載最近是一個眾人恐懼我貪婪的狀況
喔 可轉載最近的價格喔 非常的差
再講一次喔 可轉載最近的價格很差
超差的
喔 有沒有看到
呃 七八十塊的有
喔 九十幾塊的一堆
喔 九十幾塊的一堆 有沒有
九十幾塊
喔來來來這裡
98塊餒有單保還98塊
有沒有
這裡啊你這一檔啊這檔各位
有沒有看到極緣ky看到很害怕對不對
嚇死了不敢買我跟各位講
他是有單保啊不要怕好不好他是有單保
你怕他倒了有單保你就不要怕了
結果他現在有單保賣98
還賣的蠻便宜的
好
多多獎最佳年
高雄廠就同學位
很多人去那邊上
好
所以現在可轉載很便宜啊
現在到一個
這個
很誇張的時候啊
現在可轉載超便宜
超便宜
很多人這個可轉載很便宜
那可轉載你
你不只從
呃
學科轉載你也可以從可轉載呢去看
那個
公司的企圖
就連大碗一樣都是
不會啦
少爺出事
嚇死人吶
哦
各位看到
昨天有講大連大
哦昨天剛好有人問大連大
我說
從可轉載的角度來看他還有機會上
哦
從可轉載的角度來看還有機會上
就是我們從微買跟市值來看嘛
微買假如帶市值就還有機會
齁 那什麼時候會沒機會呢
齁 從什麼時候會沒機會 就是
當那個 呃 當有套利的時候
就比較沒機會啦
也不是說一定沒機會 至少比較沒機會 來來來
我就來說 來看這個是科巧
科巧
這個相對來講 機會小了點
齁 各位有沒有看到 來看科巧
可笑也是蠻強的喔 對不對 蠻強的嘛
可是他相對來講機會小一點 為什麼 因為他可轉載已經在換了
他換了就算了 還折價現在市值213 那202賤賣 有有沒有看到有人在賤賣可轉載有人在95折賤賣可轉載
95折賤賣可轉載
春夏秋冬電腦軟體是當中神器
當中神器有
這邊
有人在賤賣可轉載
所以當你看到這種賤賣可轉載
其實
股票的高檔可能就要小心了
所以你可以從可轉載裡面
可以看得出來一些東西啊
可轉載看得出來一些東西
好
來我們
這個歡迎各位報可轉載啊可轉載這個
欸這個
可轉載是
剩台北場而已啦剩台北場
好那我們今天來講一下
來講一下最近
那個
分點有在買
那你可以從這裡找
找那種
分點異常買得多的
從分點加取神秘券商
分點異常
就看得到
最近的強盛星在大買
北極星
趙鋒中立
把它敲開
敲開
爆大量拉漲停
哦
永豐金台南
呵呵
創意子發財是不是要出事
不會啦
那會嚴重
應該不會啦
哦
然後呢呃九陽
哇九陽這個
這富方新主吃很多
吃很多所以你可以可以各位可以從這裡找
找看看有沒有低檔人家吃很多的
我一直有吃
金利呢凱基辛龍有吃
數字的台銀高雄這也吃
歷士的凱基城中也吃
這些
還有這個程訊科的台中港
義航,義航這個我是沒有很喜歡的
義航花輪昌林口
在這裡吃
股價很低啊
股價很低
所以
這裡呢你可以從這邊呢去找到那個
大單有在買的
你也可以從這邊去找
大單有在賣的
這邊有一些是大單有在賣的
單有在賣的
單有在賣
我來看異常
台陽
台陽這個
雲大新竹賣
玉山新竹賣
浩宇是原富城東賣
這是比較低檔
六輝是富邦主客賣
嗯
其實我說低檔有人大賣也不太好
可能真的是
可能是出了問題
抽中華怎麼領取啊
去那個去粉專領
去粉專留下你的這個
留下你的聯絡方式還有全家
喔全家
好所以這邊呢各位可以從這裡找
找有大買有大賣的
那我們喜歡低檔大買喜歡高昂大賣
喜歡低檔大買高昂大賣
好 以上就是這個從那邊找
欸 有問
上尾投控庫藏股很多次沒有漲
最近的封電都很弱啊
永冠出事之後
整個封電族群大家會怕
特別弱一點
那永冠最近是拉了幾根漲田
今天應該有人出貨了
今天這個去拉漲田的可能今天要出了
你看 市政了
他去敲了 已經出掉
就這樣子
好
所以
欸
這個
各位的
要看怎麼樣找
神秘券商你可以從這邊找
那也可以從PVE裡面找
PVE呢也會教各位
怎麼看這個神秘券商
PVE也會有
今天也有這個神秘券商啊
神秘券商今天也有
這邊也有
我們來看一下
例如說最近
最近各位看黛宇
趙瘋大同
庫長股在買
他有在買
黛宇的殼轉在很便宜
他光這個殼轉在
他光這個
光這個庫長股買了一億
庫長股買一億喔
然後各位你猜他會不會倒
他庫長股就可以拿1出來買然後他的這個發2億可准再發2億 張先生還有5億
他會不會為了這2億而讓自己選擇倒閉
我是覺得機會是
蠻低的啦 因為他有10次庫藏股
第一個有10次庫藏股
有10次庫藏股我覺得就不容易倒
他第二個呢
歷年來大部分都有配息
疫情的時候還配過7塊
這至少去年還有配
今年還沒決議
今年還沒決議出來
歷年來都有配息
倒的機率也比較低
倒的機率低
但是目前
各位啊
你現在買帶雨4的殖利率高達9%
嚇死人了
你現在買一年後怎麼
怎麼樣 一年後102收耶
102耶 我們100耶
93102收耶
所以最近的可轉帳真的是風聲鶴唳
風聲鶴唳 自從永冠事件之後
風聲鶴唳
大家嚇死
所以導致永冠 導致現在有一堆可轉帳很便宜
即便這個看起來 因為我們看他會不會倒
就會看這個發行的金額啦
越少的越不會倒
你可以這樣想嗎
這有人跟你借錢會借了100塊就倒了嗎
呵呵 借100塊然後倒了跑了不理你
好歹借多一點嘛 好歹也發多一點再來倒
發個兩億倒
這個不服
不服效益啦 我是覺得不服效益
然後他現在還有張的線金 他也不是什麼
也不是什麼KY股 也有在配息的
所以我覺得 也有實質庫藏股
我是覺得他倒的機率是相對低很多
就這樣說 所以
這個目前可轉載有很多這種
這種很
很奇葩的
很奇葩的低價
喔 好
好啦 那
欸 來來來來 我們再往下看
所以各位呢 你要了解可轉載 可以上可轉載
你要知道處置策略的
我們禮拜是有體驗課
體驗課歡迎各位上
體驗課的報名 就在這邊
各位記得要加會員才能報
這是理財寶的體驗課
我們會
這策略呢我們會先講一些基礎的概念基礎概念會先講跟各位講什麼叫處置有的人什麼叫儲置都不懂那其實儲置呢會讓盤中
會讓那個股價呢
會有點波動
好 以上
就是這樣子啦
這樣子 有興趣的
歡迎報名
好 那最後呢
最後
今天呢有籌碼
會送443檔大陸會選新單
有需要可以購買
好 然後
最後最後最後
買抽卡可以加入抽卡可以社團啊
喜歡今天直播歡迎按讚訂閱留言觀看心得
我們之後後面要抽
呃
景品娃娃喔留言觀看心得會抽景品娃娃跟軟體
這留言觀看心得
那現場QA時間呢不要從後面有抽獎
這抽獎抽的是
軟體
後面有抽獎
我關好一下軟體啊
都會有人誤會
說不是軟體
我抽軟體而已啊
這抽軟體
好
那今天的問題就是
可準在入門基礎班台北場是只要上課
好
這個
歡迎各位
聽一下
哇!台子期貨上漲300點
這是什麼
我覺得這個
這台字體真的很誇張
好 這個我們現在來抽一下
台字體很誇張啦 超誇張
來 先來抽這個亂數產生來 亂數產生氣啊
1到30
9跟17號
好啦 這個
接下來
給各位問問題
問問題啊 歡迎各位問
這個 先別問股票
因為問股票問不完了
我們每天一堆要回答一堆學員問股票的問題
然後每天我們還會整理 現在都整理
整理學員的問題
整理完
來有沒有看到 這裡
哇 這裡有一堆學員的問題
每天很多啊
問籌碼的 一堆的 問裡面一堆
有66個問題 我們都會用AI整理完
然後寫出來
WBC冠亞去怎麼看
這個蠻好玩的
但是我覺得美國還是比較有機會啦
畢竟全員都是大聯盟啊
對 全大聯盟
跟谷宇有聯絡嗎
前幾天有看過他 前幾天有在錄PBE有看過他
你要找他嗎 你要找谷宇嗎
有看過他啊
什麼開當中課
下半年了
應該是下半年
可能庫長股有買嗎
有
可能庫長股是每次都會參加的啦
好不好
他的庫長股
其實在低檔都是品質保證的
你看低檔都有漲上來
對不對
這D檔啦 都會長
那現在又是D檔
我們這D檔
所以人家這禮拜四上下 對
可轉在有科後可以看嗎 有
美國一定贏 因為對方總統在他手上
對
委內瑞拉敢贏
對 敢贏了把總統給殺
呵呵呵
把總統推上那個
喔 推上台
有上過經濟拳道還需要上次的可想
欸 你可以選擇不要啦
因為我覺得
基本的
概念差不多啦
我們只有加新的案例而已
概念差不多啦 你可以選擇不用
會買華泰可轉載嗎
我覺得 我是買華泰現股啦
來 給各位看華泰可轉載23291
還沒上市 明天
明天就看到了 可能就是
呃 很有可能110開啊
有可能漲停開啊
可能有可能漲停開出
被動算是夏天嗎?
呃
我們
我們這個有
去篩籌碼
他有可能的型態是夏天啊
但是我們有去篩籌碼
喔有去篩籌碼
所以目前夏天的股票這些
各位可以看一下
那
沒篩出來可能就
就...可能就沒有
哇!進棚夏天耶
夏天來了
那各位你可以從夏天裡面找強勢股啊
夏天這麼強
夏天好強喔
夏天的股就很強
秋天的股
有沒有這麼強
沒有!
沒有
秋天最強的就榮田
秋天就沒那麼強
夏天比較強啦
CP折價時買入不叫科研軟件
是否可以套利
對啊 可以套利啊
但是大部分你折很多的時候都沒得套
因為大部分都是
龍券 殼轉带不能換
殼轉带不能換
整個看現在中東問題
中東問題喔 我跟各位講
沒有地面站
大概不容易結束啦
喔 啊地面站
那麼難打 地面站難打的啊
地面站
對不對 地面站總不能拍個
月... 總不能拍個那個
這個陸戰隊去 然後去
去...去...去...去那麼大的伊朗
對 伊朗 面積跟...
伊朗面積超大啊 跟新疆差不多啊
對
這個 不大容易啊
好
商榮發債股價受壓抑喔 來看一下3月27日 啊7日3月16日呃...很有可能
很有可能股價受壓抑
欸!雙紅呢!
欸各位啊
雙紅
我有想要用雙紅跟某一檔配
喔雙紅是可以跟某一檔配的
我看一下我先看一下
那一檔也差不多快要了
快要出事情了
好,再兩天,好啦
再給他一天時間
雙紅可以跟這個另外一檔配,還不錯
曾經在哪一集講過春夏秋冬篩選的東西?
我們在PP裡面也有篩選的參數
啊篩選的邏輯精神喔 歡迎你去看那個
那個課啦 處置
看那個PP的四季課 那個四季課蠻清楚的
蠻清楚的 怎麼看大盤喔
我是覺得波動很大
春夏秋冬是新課程那種 現在有篩選的條件啦
啊春夏秋冬的那個有
有那個春夏秋冬的三月條件有寫出來
然後課程的
新課程的內容還沒上架
快上架
明天嘎爆空軍
我現在的單子是多單比較多
可轉載是還好
可短債我覺得 你明天看嘛
因為華泰他這個市值滿高的
所以可短債搞不好會開找點不確定
當神器全方位會怎麼盤中當下要衝的股票
其實做多的可以盤中看那個
做多的看這些啦
你各位看喔
做多的會從全方位的做多找做多
再講一次喔
做多的是從全方位的做多找做多
各位有沒有看到 這裡啊
做多找做多 這裡有很多啊
哇 我就不用做了喔
哇 我是跳空就一字線了
會從前方位的做多找做多
那做空呢
呃 有的從這裡找有的從隔日沖找齁 就這樣3月4號課程是QRcode版明對 就是剛剛這個QRcode
各位要報的 趕緊報啦
他有名額限制的啦
有名額限制的
這裡 處置策略
齁 在這裡
再生明天出發還有戲嗎
沒辦法回答明天的問題
回答明天的問題就會影響到明天的答案
好
那歡迎各位在底下留言喔
底下留言我們可以抽
哇我可以抽哆啦A夢
可以抽哆啦A夢
這個或者是魯魯米都可以啊
好
魯魯米哆啦A夢
哼魯米哆啦A夢
這個歡迎在底下留言
在那個在YouTube底下留言
好啦
那我們今天的直播就講到這邊啊
欸 瑞宣傳處置有低頭嗎
處置我們低頭我們有個關鍵數字
我看位階啦
這個肯定有低頭啦
這低那麼
低那麼多了
有啦 低了啦
低了
群聯科轉戰1加58現場秋天或許還有戲嗎
我覺得
我覺得很難講
他那個1價58很誇張
旺宏處置的話可以買
我跟各位講
旺宏處置是個超級
假如有跌的話
再跟各位講
旺宏處置有跌的話
他就是一個超級無敵好的
可以問華東
華東只是弱勢反彈而已啦
不用太安心啦
他還沒辦法變得很強勢啦
他就是個弱勢反彈
好不好
反彈好不好
這個元大管錢大賣
好不好
元大管錢公司賣大賣
賣給誰
賣給隔日聰
當隔日聰遇到大股東
這元大管錢就是大股東了
當大股東遇到隔日聰
今天元大管錢是賣給了
元大管錢今天是賣給了
賣給了隔日聰
當葛之聰遇到
這個葛之聰遇到大股東
喔 是這樣子啊
好啦 反正我跟各位講明天華東在漲元大管錢他也想賣啊啊 對不對他已經在賣了嘛 他昨天有賣前天有賣 大前天有賣 對不對
每天賣200張 今天漲停 都給你啊 都給你
要來都給你 今天賣1400張
我賣1400張
就這樣子啊 我賣1400張 都給你 你要來都給你
就這樣 喔
那這元大他就吃很多嘛
好啦 我是覺得他今天吃
就是
也吃蠻飽的
吃飽啦 吃飽啦
好
那個
好賣一直賣
對啊 都有理啊
明天各位 你就可以觀察華東啦
好不好
明天呢 各位明天
肌體股很刺激的喔
好不好 很刺激的
滑東要出貨 威剛 旺宏
這個要躲處置
明天記憶體很好玩啦
波動一定很大 跟各位講
明天的成交量就在記憶體
好不好 再跟各位講明天的成交量
明天大家的目光全部都在記憶體
都在記憶體
明天的那個成交量
記憶體肯定是大的 旺宏肯定是大的啦
除非他跳功一次線說是
我是覺得難度越來越高
明天的成交量啊
成交量
會在記憶體啊 立基店啊 滑幫店
明天都會在記憶體啦 明天很刺激啦
明天記憶體有保安群 當然有啊
好不好
明天有啊 立基店
這個
明天你就看記憶體啊 明天記憶體超好看
超好看的啦 超好看的
蠻好看的
你就把那個望宏
那個望宏
利基電啊
這個華東啊
放在一起看
很好玩
波動都大
波動都超大
明天希望那個
那個
巴黎粒
來買記憶體
呵呵呵
明天很好看啦
明天很好看
明天
明天怎麼樣我不知道
明天假如
望宏挑弓一支線鎖死
對不對
那當然
記憶體還是有機會
好不好
那你就等著看他不會鎖死啦
好啦
那我們就講到這邊啦
這個
我要來錄PP啦
那感謝各位觀看我的直播
那我們來錄PP了
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕